[Music]
from the guy who reinvented the zombie
genre
by making it more grounded relationship
focused and hyper violent
comes a reinvention of the superhero
genre that makes it more grounded
relationship focused and hyper violent
look out movie musicals
you're about to get kirkmanned
invincible from lexcorp
comes another grim story about how
superheroes would behave if they were
real
no the other one no the other one on
amazon
meet mark grayson an ordinary teen who
discovers he's secretly part alien
and possibly part canadian sorry i'll be
right back
sorry about your apartment sorry about
this i've been there
and i'm sorry i didn't realize that
sooner sorry
sorry sorry hi sorry sorry sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry i am so sorry
i know i'm sorry i
suck he's an everyman for the zoomer
generation
which means he's extremely depressed
horny and resents having to actually do
anything with his abilities
i can't believe i still have to exercise
but he'll have to harness all of his
strength
to battle exotic villains protect his
friends
and gain one single clue across an
entire season of television
hey i didn't invent the rules what rules
it's kind of like peeing your pants on
purpose
what what's going on what oh
okay there's so much you don't know mark
what
okay you're superman and your dad is
thanos mark you are a comic book nerd
you should get this
immediately get to know wild characters
like
omniman a guy with the most intimidating
superpower of all
dad strength he's mark's father and a
clever subversion of every boy's fantasy
that their dad could beat up your dad
like this there's also amber mark's
girlfriend
who totally cracked his secret identity
totally
you know i'm not an idiot i figured it
out weeks ago
who was that the police are on their way
where the hell did you go
sandra oh in a dual row as an important
character's mother
and a different important character's
wife and the guardians of the globe
the washington generals of superhero
teens they're here to do two important
things
kill time until invincible or any man
shows up and use their superpowers to
get around age of consent laws
i don't look it but i'm 24 years old i'm
a 30 year old genius
in a teenage boy's body i never expanded
myself to that extent
that was intense explore a vast and
entirely original comic book universe
when it was first published back in 2003
that took care to update some of the old
tropes
but still has a ton of jokes you'll be
hearing the second time around
like clones who can't decide which one
is the original i'm the original
he told me you're the clone what do you
think he told me you're the clone
fashion designers who secretly
specialize in hero costumes
i'll strive for iconic knuckles a
friendly alien voiced by seth rogen
are you using your timeout it's probing
time and
robot-headed mafia bosses i've got
money it gives me no joy to do this
because clamps will be doing it jeez
there are multiple animated comedies
featuring wacky robot godfathers
maybe we should try a new genre once in
a while hey anyone up for bringing back
the horny ski comedy
[Music]
so marvel at a show so dense with ayla's
celebrities
it's super clear that amazon can afford
to give its drivers bathroom breaks
or at least improve the animation when
it's not part of the fight scene in this
show that combines the look of a 90s
cartoon
with tons of fun twists recurring jokes
and
hey wait i wasn't done okay why would
you drop the credits like that the
episode clearly isn't over
there's like two more minutes left see
starring
young justice get me pictures of omni
man
wait i'll do it how i pet your mother i
wish that i had joker's girl
nicole the pink ranger doltron
jason mandzukic as himself you'll do
what i don't know
probably explode something oh maybe
you're nuts
and subway eat fresh
splotchmen
do you guys notice the invincible shirt
that i put in that other movie where i
voiced an alien
you see you plant the seed and then you
[ __ ] the plant
[Laughter]
[Music]
the loki series drops tomorrow but
before you watch that
we asked a real psychiatrist to tell us
what's loki's whole you know deal
what's wrong with that guy sickle puppy
needs some therapy click the thumbnail
on the right to see how they'd really
treat the god of mischief
happy eighth wedding anniversary
christian june 8
2021 i taught a tall a puddi zombie tat
six seasons and a movie even if the
movie ends up being inside an episode of
rick and morty
i am the poo poo overlord now bow
before me